ma la lega osta e questo è un gioco
particolare perché oggi vi faccio capire
che cosa significa essere multitasking e
le donne lo sono gli uomini no c'è nel
senso io ho notato questa cosa quando io
parlo ad esempio con una mia amica
eccetera che io sto facendo le cose al
telefono e io sento solo
luigi e poi finisco di scrivere e dico
scusami non ho sentito che non riesce a
scrivere ad ascoltarmi nel mentre è il
risposta è no io non riesco a fare due
cose insieme
esiste double doger sky questo gioco che
ti permette di fare due così sia invece
tu devi giocare non so anche altri così
devi giocare schivare delle robe nel
gioco ok nel gioco del sesso ipoteche
camini e rischia da roma nel mentre che
cammini tu devi fare un gioco sullo
smartphone quindi io devo fare tu giochi
in uno il che è veramente un casino
aspetta
dio mio sfasata tre giochi nulla è
difficilissimo fare tutto insieme
edifici teatro dove diavolo stai
camminando che ci sono i stava dicendo
dove diavolo stai camminando di soli
tombini aperti il quale città esistono i
tombini aperti tutta la città c'è ma che
è giù per il tubo cos'è sta roba
qualcuno si ricorda giù per il tubo sono
solo di averlo visto la mia vita gay no
anche se la stretta non finire in strada
nuovo record face whitby che fu balocchi
mia mamma che mi dice stai attento
quando torni a casa ci sono dei lavori
sulla strada
questo mi ha scritto mia mamma grazie
mamma non me ne sono ancora corto perché
sto giocando a questo gioco che poteva
saltare anche la schermata perché io
vado giù porco demoni e mi sismiche la
schermata dove sbaglio tasto devo
battere record di prima che 551 ce la
faccio
non riesco a fare loro vinse me io mi
trovo veramente in difficoltà ma questa
volta ce la faccio be careful with
walking omnia esattamente mia mamma
welfare
fortunatamente milano non è così quando
tornò tutto è già il gioco in sé è
carino figurati quanto le hanno fatte
bene le unghie i tuoi o comunque record
perché se io esulto e il per dire record
non sto attento al gioco è normale è una
cosa normale la cosa che mi sorprende di
più ragazzi ve lo giuro
la cosa che mi sorprende che quella roba
l'ostacolo nel gioco non lavora anche
visto è talmente sono poco multitasking
che non l'avevo neanche visto con lo
stato li me ne sono accorto quando sono
morto e c'era un ostacolo perfetto
adesso prova concentra perché poi in
tutto questi devo anche commentare
quindi non è neanche c'è un livello di
difficoltà in più ragazzi non è facile
vi giuro arrivare almeno a mia almeno a
mille porca vacca non è per niente
semplice grazie mamma wanda vile
messaggi e voglio può leggere in questo
momento che puoi morire nel gioco è
molto meno tragico che morire mentre
cammino quindi ancora peggio ok perfetto
non mi capiteranno d'ostacoli stima e
sarà veramente la fine del mondo ok
record sono al record non mi esalto
perché prima per esaltarli sono morto
quindi a posto la cena e alle 6 patate
con i broccoli preferisco cadere nei
tombini
meno male che me l'hai detto mamma oddio
fanno faccio qua non sarà che la vedevo
neanche la strada meno male sto
arrivando a mille rega sono un fire
non sarà che questo facendo proprio lui
novecento e adesso si interessa sinistra
sinistra molto bene ecco invece la media
destra porca vacca headphone connected
adesso la musica è diventata più potente
perché cielo nelle cuffie va bene ma che
hai fatto bene sto gioco raga allora
2000 che cosa c'è dio miracolo in cui
già adesso sta diventando un problema il
gioco si è velocizzato con l'esterno con
all interno di governo come è andata a
scuola
hai portato dei moti mamma per uno che
gioca me per la strada in mezzo ai
tombini spera di non avere voti perché
fidati sono tutti negativi
la donna cos'ha fatto
[Musica]
aiuto magari è possibile forse no ma
sabato c'è nei cinque minuti va bene
mamma aiuto chiama papa chiama
l'ambulanza già che ci siamo noi ragazzi
aiuto e impulso veramente headphone
connection lost sono fatta perché sto
facendo nostro capace lag e
difficilissimo lo giuro aiuto no ma poi
sono calati in un pochino dai 1700
ragazzi è difficilissimo farmi partire
almeno da 1900 forse meglio che riparto
da zero che sono scarsi ma don ragazzi
veramente difficilissimo vice mauro il
gioco assurdo prova a battere il mio è
difficile non so se riuscirò mai a
battere il mio record veramente un
casino però proviamo perché il record è
dato tutto dal punteggio dal gioco
dentro lo smartphone che tanto sembra
una saponetta con un tasto però avere
perché sembra una cagata ma la parte
iniziale la fee bastarda perché quello
che non vedi c'è nel senso tu non vendo
un fai attenzione agli ostacoli perché
dici vabbè è tutto lento e invece questo
è comunque un gioco con una morale non
giocate con gli smartphone mentre
camminate per strada vi prego
cena alle 6 patate broccoli grazie mamma
meno male che sono morto nel tombino
meno male è il phon connected che sia
privati a mille miglia arrivare a 1700
saranno veramente impegnare scusatemi
c'è una concentrazione che non ho avuto
neanche lady esami di stato sana un
centravanti
ok paola toschi bene mamma tutto a posto
arrivò come un sacco di insufficienze ti
piacciono due bei 4 sul tavolo e poi
vado a giocare alla playstation
tutto mentre il cammino per strada è
unica in campania come gli e bambini
normali gioco anche a port nike a
nessuno porco lemonia c'è nei 5 minuti
è da due ore che ci sono i cinque stati
un po quasi record
dovrei dire l'asta cagata ma fa niente
connection lost dio dio lavorando non è
vero 1700 1600 99 per essere precisi
porco demonio c'era un altro gioco che
era molto simile vedremo solo becco
credo sia questo ragazzino vorrei dire
cagate multi task e vecchissimo si è
questo allora questa è l'asse e lo
stesso principio di quell'altro
semplicemente un po più un po più sotto
ac di alice una cagata e ti mette più
giochi e tu devi stare attento a tutti
quanti
semplicemente il punteggio sta in base a
quanto resisti ai secondi ma dovranno il
dato non sbagliando ok per adesso è
facile tenere la palla di sinistra e
tenere il coso lì vive fra le parti di
avere una capacità del cervello che io
non ho quindi vabbè l'abbiamo fatto una
volta sul canale sicuro l'avevo fatto
sta che andava pazzo lo sta roba io
quand'ero un gagno ok
oh mio dio mio dio mio dio
perfetto
perfetto per ora gestibile è un po un
casino ma è gestibile porco demonio ok
attrezzati ok
perfetto perfetto perfetto adesso
diventa un casino ok se va beh sì in
un'altra vita for raga riflessivi aiuto
aiuto
poi non riesco non capiscono anche
pitassi a un certo punto
madonna ha senso non sono tutti e cioè
tutti sono sei se non sbaglio ma ben
fattibile
madonna e vabbè si poteva fare ne faccio
un'altra ragazzi multitasche non è
facile però la cosa è che l'inizio è
veramente una cazzata
e proprio quando dovrebbe dovrebbero
farmi partire tenente la 100ma ho fatto
prima ad arrivare a 100 non si può
arrivare neanche a 100 il tuo gioco non
so come ho fatto prima ve lo giuro
infatti inguardabile io con lei nata
adesso non la sto guardando meno male
che non si si si orco demonio nora io
vada illegale e studioso e la
l'anticristo quanto fatto 108 prima nova
non ci arriverò mai più 100 aspetta
aspetta aspetta 108 attenzione lo batte
lo batte record aiuto sto facendo un
casino
tutto velocizzato certo certo era
proprio quello di cui hanno bisogno mica
perdo l'ho preso l'ho preso porco
demonio sono cascato quali in alto
no era infatti perché stavo perdendo in
due giochi io ho perso in due giochi
insieme ho perso sia ancora in basso a
destra che con in alto a sinistra
basta non voglio più vedere niente il
tutto ciò ma dicevo io veramente non
riesco a mandare un messaggio e
ascoltare una persona nello stesso
momento
quindi mi ricordo una volta mi ha fatto
un discorso anima eravamo in camera
eravamo in casa sua e lui mi aveva detto
vieni a fargli compagnia di là che sto
montando un video e io come fai a
commentare un video se uno ti parla io
non riuscirei mai lasciato un bel
commento cazzotto sul vostro punteggio
se lo avete fatto oppure se siete
multitasking non fatemelo sapere perché
voglio leggere un po su questo argomento
sono interessato credo che sia opportuno
sviluppare la seconda area del cervello
per essere multitasking
io non ho neanche la prima quindi ci
vediamo al prossimo video e da ragazzi
[Musica]